there's no doubt about it Christof is an
absolute sweetheart
but there's something fishy about him or
rather his past we've got some theories
about what happened to Christoph's
parents that may shock you
watch until the end to find out why
christophe might not be who we think he
is christophe is a sami outdoorsman who
works as an ice Harvester he was raised
by trolls and would much rather hang out
with his reindeer Sven than real-life
people he's a fixer-upper with a heart
of gold but when it comes to his
childhood it's all smoke and mirrors
according to co-director Jennifer Lee
Kristoff grew up in an orphanage but his
free spirit stopped him from following
the rules causing him to sneak out and
seek out the wilderness at eight years
old Kristoff was adopted by Balda and
raised by a colony of trolls
Christoph's parents allegedly gave him
up when he was just a kid which led him
to grow up in an orphanage Christoph's
parents are a total mystery he doesn't
remember anything about them all he
remembers before meeting the trolls is
his reindeer Sven
it's been revealed that Kristoff is a
Sami and the Sammis are indigenous
people who live in northern Europe
they're known for living outdoors he
lives in northern Sweden Norway and
Finland
although Sammis are usually fishermen
and trappers they also herd raindeers
and keep them as companions so it's safe
to assume that Christoph's parents were
from a Sami tribe this explains why Sven
and Kristoff have been inseparable since
birth something terrible must have
happened to Christoph's parents why else
would they leave him in an orphanage
it's possible that Christoph's parents
for reindeer herders who passed away on
the job and never came home with no one
left to race him Kristoff was left at an
orphanage with Sven who would be a clear
reminder of Christoph's heritage but
since nature was in his blood Kristoff
couldn't help but run away and seek out
the wilderness this theory makes total
sense but there might be more to
Christoph childhood than meets the eye
to say that Christoph likes ice cream
would be an understatement when he was
just a toddler he began following a
group of ice harvesters around and
copying their every move after poking
around we realized something pretty
strange Christophe is wearing Harvester
clothing and since orphans don't have
money to buy handcrafted outfits this
sort of makes no sense to add fuel to
the fire the harvesters seemed to be
taking care of Chris
which makes us think that his biological
father's among the harvesters but wait
isn't Christophe an orphan well we're
not exactly sure that's the truth
what if Christoph's mother was a Sammy
who fell in love with an ice Harvester
since mixing with the outside world was
forbidden raising a half Sammy wouldn't
have been an option so after giving
birth to Kristoff his mom might have
given up her baby to his biological
father but since she'd won Kristoff to
know about his heritage she left a baby
reindeer by his side knowing that they
would take care of each other this would
explain Christoph's heritage and why he
has a pet reindeer and the knack for ice
harvesting but why would Kristoff
believe that he is nor Fionn and why is
his past so uncertain
well there's an explanation for that
after a long night of ice harvesting
Kristoff and Sven were on their way home
when they saw two riders leaving the ice
trail through the forest they followed
the mysterious riders into a clearing
where they witnessed the king and queen
of arendelle talking to trolls about
their daughters powers the trolls wiped
Ana's memory before Christoph's of very
eyes but before he could go home a troll
named bull de found him and said instead
of asking him if he was lost bold a
basically kidnapped Kristoff in a very
subtle Disney type of way while the
trolls and frozen are absolutely
adorable and kind there are many reasons
to believe that this is all an act in
Scandinavian history it was common
knowledge that trolls used to steal
young children and bring them into the
mountains those who would manage to get
away would often experience bouts of
confusion some even lost their memories
altogether it's possible that Volda
erased Christoph's memories making him
believe that he was nor Fionn this way
he wouldn't want to run away it's also
said that the trolls could procure a
changeling which is a carbon copy of a
child they just stole they'd send this
changeling back to the child's parents
so that they'd be none the wiser but
there'd be something off about the
changeling and many parents would soon
realize that their child had been
replaced
Christoph's childhood is a blur which
makes us believe that his memories were
indeed erased by the trolls during Anna
and Christoph's first sleigh ride
Kristoff scolds Anna for getting engaged
to a stranger didn't your parents ever
warn you about strangers and the fact
that Kristoff says this makes us think
that he does in fact remember his
parents but can't recall their names or
faces
balda definitely didn't teach him this
last
because well she was the stranger he
shouldn't have trusted if Bowl de anza
pabbie really did erase Christoph's
memories this means that Christoph's
parents are probably still alive but
whether or not they're still looking for
him is up for debate it's safe to say
that the trolls and frozen's seem like
genuinely kind people christophe is far
from being a prisoner and the trolls
help those in need while we don't know
exactly what happened to Christoph's
parents there are only a few possible
options either his parents tragically
passed away in a typical Disney fashion
or Kristoff wandered off and was later
adopted by bull de we would love to find
out about Christoph's past and frozen to
if his parents are still alive there's a
very good reason that we'll meet them in
the upcoming sequel or perhaps we'll
find out what really happened to them so
do you guys think that Christoph's
parents passed away when he was a young
baby or are his parents out there
searching for their long-lost son who
wandered into the woods and never
returned let us know what your theories
are down below and that's a wrap for
more videos about your favorite Disney
characters hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up while you're at it thanks for
watching the things we'll catch you next
time
[Music]